important day tomorrow isn't it the
introduction of the
oxford astra zenica vaccine uh a big
step in our
route out of this yes it's a huge step
um the thing about the astrazeneca
vaccine is that it's very simple to
administer it's like a kind of flu jab
the question is how we get an
accelerated program for vaccination
which allows us to increase the
production of the the vaccines
my understanding is that astrazeneca not
this week or next but the week after
should be able to get up to two million
vaccines
uh a week i think they can probably if
they know that
the system can absorb more do more than
that
and you could end up with three million
vaccines per week
in february coming from astrazeneca
alone
and then you've got the fisa vaccine of
course which is more complicated but
still we've got
significant amounts of that and then
there's the johnson johnson american
vaccine
which again is a relatively simple one
to administer we booked
30 million doses of that with an option
for a further 22 million we should
exercise that option
we should try and get that on stream in
february as well
and what we're trying to say today is
that
you really need to change this radically
now
and in order to make sure that
sorry about that we really need to
change strategy radically now
in order to make sure that we're getting
vaccination done at a far
faster rate than is presently uh
considered yeah a few noises off there
uh we'll we'll plow on and boris johnson
said today
that the hope is that tens of millions
of jabs will be delivered
in the next three months isn't he
essentially saying what what you're
saying
yeah but i don't think you see i i think
we're still
either thinking it's 1 million
vaccinations a week
2 million maximum what i'm really saying
is
we need now completely to reconsider our
strategy in order to get the whole
country vaccinated much much faster we
should be
as soon as the vaccines are available we
should be getting them to people
and using them and that requires a a
different type of strategy because you
need to use
all the gp services that you've got all
the services within the health service
of course
uh you need to be using um pharmacies
every bit of um you know the pharmacies
that do the normal flu jab we should be
using for this vaccine as well
occupational health workers we should be
training more volunteers
we need to mobilize resources on a scale
that we've never seen before in
peacetime in this country
because this new variant of um
the disease is much more easily
transmissible
you've also got the potential for this
south african strain
to be a very problematic strain
developing in the country
and therefore what was good as a
vaccination program a month ago
is not good enough today i know the nhs
has done an amazing job it's a herculean
effort to get as far as they have
but unfortunately we're now in a new
situation and therefore
we have to we have to accelerate this
strategy in a profound way
yeah but sorry well
i guess the government will say that's
exactly what they are doing and britain
is leading the way globally with its
vaccine rollout i've been reading your
document you're talking about maximizing
the quantity of vaccines and the speed
they're available using the largest
number of venues
where possible recruiting and training
uh preparing uh
data capture and data sharing systems i
mean the government is doing all of this
isn't it
no no no no they're not doing all of it
yet
by any means i think right now there's a
significant number
of uh gp practices that i'm doing
vaccinations
um pharmacies there's a limit on the
number of pharmacies we're using
i'm not sure the exact number of
volunteers we train but there's nothing
like the amount we're talking about
and then i don't think we're using
occupational health workers at all
so no we're not we're not at the
situation yet where we're using
every single available um piece of
infrastructure that we could
now i'm not criticizing the government
over this i'm sure they're now
considering it
but what we've tried to suggest in this
paper are very practical ways
that you can get if necessary and if we
can if the vaccines are available
and i think they should be because of
these new vaccines that are coming on
stream
you know we we should be doing as much
vaccination
as we've got vaccines available and it's
in the end it's a logistics challenge
it's a challenge of organization and
because these new vaccines
are much simpler to administer than the
pfizer vaccine they don't require the
same storage
they don't require the same observation
of patients after vaccinated
they're much easier to administer we
should be able to do this
at a vastly increased scale i'm not
criticizing the government i'm simply
setting out
what could be a way that you could
vaccinate the entire population
in a in a matter of weeks you can only
you can only
give those vaccinations to people if
they're produced and astrazeneca said
they can do
two million a week but isn't it down to
the production there's only a finite
number you can produce
sure but the question is can you get
that up i think what you'll find with a
lot of these manufacturers
is that because of these vaccines once
you produce them they've got a half-life
as it were
in other words you've got to use them
within a certain specified
amount of time i think what you'll find
if you talk in detail to the
manufacturers
is they'll say we can manufacture more
provided you can tell us that your
system can absorb that number of
vaccines
so if you take for example this johnson
johnson vaccine there's a single dose
vaccine by the way
or it is at least at the at the moment
uh predicated as a single vote dose
vaccine
they've got my understanding is they've
got very very good capability
manufacturing capability actually in
europe they could probably vaccin
they could probably produce as many
vaccines as we
needed so that and astrazeneca alone
should give you the ability to vaccinate
larger numbers of people
their problem is they won't want to
produce those vaccines
unless you can show you've got a plan
that if they produce them you could use
them
yeah good point um let's talk a bit
about schools uh do you think
schools should be going back tomorrow we
know some primaries obviously in london
and elsewhere aren't
um it's a tough one isn't it it is a
tough one yeah because
on the one hand it's it's a disaster for
children but especially poorer children
if they can't get back into school on
the other hand it's not so much the risk
to children per se because
children aren't unlikely to get ill from
this disease so it's very very rare
it's the transmission and with this new
variant it
be more transmissible it's a very very
difficult situation so you've got to
just keep it under advice
day by day i think but the problem is
that
all all that this does is it puts you
back into the same
essential dilemma which is
absent mass vaccination you're in locked
out
this is why i think you you've got to
treat this vaccination program
differently now it's literally the only
way out
of a severe lockdown and as we know
every week that we lock down we destroy
businesses
and jobs there are huge health
consequences of it and of course schools
of education as well
so do you think we should have tougher
restrictions i mean boris johnson saying
they may be around the corner do we need
to bring those in now
look i i guess that they're they're
looking with their
chief scientists at all the data and i
i'm not
you know i'm not sitting in front of
them so it's difficult and i wouldn't
want to second-guess them on it
but the basic problem they've got is
that
if you're a teacher or a parent you're
going to be really worried about sending
your child to school not so much because
your child might be at risk
but what if they catch the disease come
back and put it into your family
and then the teachers themselves of
course are going to be worried now there
may be parts of the country where the
disease level
is very low and it may be easier then to
to get the schools open
i i don't think i honestly don't think
there's an answer to this it's going to
be extremely difficult to keep schools
open
but what it does is bring you back to
the basic point
you've got to get this vaccination thing
accelerated even though they've done an
amazing job
to to vaccinate as many as we have now
it's got to be radically accelerated
and finally just briefly uh it's great
to have you on of of course but do you
think labour is doing enough to
challenge the government
on particularly on the on the school's
issue i mean sakia stamina doesn't seem
to have taken a position on it yet
well i think the labor party is pressing
the government very hard but you know
it's always difficult as an opposition
because there's bits of information you
won't have and
you know you you're always in a bit of a
bind where
you don't want people to think you're
just point scoring on the other hand
you've got to keep the government to
account
i mean i actually think kirsten is doing
a pretty good job of that um
but it's it's you know this is not
really a political
challenge in the end it's it's not labor
or tory i mean
whichever government was in power this
is the biggest problem i've ever seen
government have to grapple with and
that's why i'm always you know i always
start
and i didn't today and i should have i
always start by saying i'm deeply
sympathetic to the people in government
i've been in the government i know how
hard it is
and these decisions are really difficult
and that's why
when we speak or indeed when the
opposition speaks that's why today we
we've given a paper with details about
how you might improve the situation
rather than saying well why isn't the
government doing a better job it's it's
really
this is a moment for constructive
suggestion as to how we get
to the end point we all want to reach
far faster